الخبر العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل حيث نقلت
شبكات سي ان ان الاخباريه الامريكيه عن
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قولها ان طائرات
بريطانيه والمانيه اعترضت الثلاثاء طائره
روسيه قرب المجال الجوي الاستوني ذهب
لمزيد من التفاصيل الى لندن ومعنى من هناك
مراسلتنا مينا
حربيات التي خرجت حول ما جرى
وحسب وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه فان مقاتله
من نوع تايفون تابعه لسلاح الجو البريطاني
ومقاتله المانيه اعترضت طائره للتزود
بالوقود روسيه كانت تحلق فوق المجال الجوي
لاستونيا بحسب الوزاره فان الطائر الروسيه
فشلت في التواصل مع جهات مراقبه الحركه
الجويه في استونيا وان اعتراضها كان امرا
روتينيا لكن هذه العمليه الاولى من نوعها
في مجال التعاون
يعني عمليه التعاون المشترك بين دول
الحلفاء في النيتو لسيمه فيما يتعلق
بالشرطه الجويه التابعه لحلف النيتو كما
ان الوزاره تضيف بان هذه العمليه التي
تجريها القوات الجويه البريطانيه
والالمانيه هي عمليات شرطه جويه مشتركه
كما ذكرت في المنطقه ضمن انشطه حلف الناتو
في هذا في هذه الاثناء يستعد سلاح الجو
البريطاني لقياده مهمه الشرطه الجويه
طويله المدى للنيتو في منطقه البلطيق من
القوات الجويه الالمانيه في ابريل المقبل
وهذا يشير الى ان الدول الحلفاء في حلف
الناتو مستعده بشكل يعني يعني وانها متاحه
يعني متاهبه للرد على اي عمليات مشبوهه
عبر المجال الجوي للدول الحلفاء في حلف
الناتو ووزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تؤكد ان
الحكومه البريطانيه والبريطانيه ملتزمه
بالدفاع عن حلفائها مهما تطلب تطلب الامر
لا سيما بعد الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
والجهود التي تبذلها لندن تحديدا في حشد
الدعم للدول الحلفاء في الناتو ولا سيما
الدول الشرقيه جناح الشرقي للاوروبي هذه
الدول التي يعني تكثف لندن جهودها من اجل
حشد الدعم الدولي لدعمها في ظل العدوان
الروسي على على اوكرانيا شكرا لك من لندن
مراسلتنا من الحربلو